an arrest has been made in connection to
a deadly crash where two people lost
their lives that crash happening last
month on jones near flamingo police say
a corvette speeding north on jones
crashed and then ended up in a parking
lot victoria saha joins us from the
crash site where police have charged
another driver who was racing that
corvette
she was a
vibrant person very alive
and
always outgoing jose velazquez is
remembering his big sister priscilla
velesquez for her bubbly personality as
he now copes with her life being cut too
short everybody is angry this is the
aftermath of the crash that killed
velasquez and her boyfriend 34-year-old
jason kuhar according to a police report
obtained by 8 news now velasquez was the
registered owner of the corvette kuhar
was driving it the report also says he
was going 140 miles per hour before he
lost control and crashed she should
still be here there's no reason
for any of it claire velasquez says
reckless driving is not something her
sister-in-law would ever condone she's
the passenger and she has no
no like fault at it but here we are
right and we're all paying for it she
paid for it with her life the
investigation revealed to the corvette
was racing against a dodge challenger
that was going 88 miles per hour metro's
fatal detectives located the driver of
that car giovanni monaris tavis on he
was arrested by police on wednesday
there's like
a million people that are that are
affected because of two people's
decisions arrest reports show manaris
tavison drove away after he witnessed a
crash the velasquez family says they
were waiting for those involved to be
held accountable and now their focus is
to care for the two teens velasquez left
behind this is going to define their
whole lives manaris tavazon is facing
felony charges of reckless driving
resulting in substantial bodily harm or
death he faced a judge yesterday and has
since posted bail he will be back in
court again in july reporting near
flamingo and jones victoria saha live
local now